back up sweet this is a nice tv i know
citizens of the reject nation going to watch
the movie black phone today and i'm joined
by the lovely and talented roxy the strider i love
it though am i more lovely or more talented this
is a terrible first impression uh you are more uh
talented i'd say yeah i was listening to uh one
of your videos with harloff i think he mentioned
the black phone and you said you hadn't seen it
and i've been wanting to watch this movie myself
so i was like this is perfect i feel like it's
right up my alley i hear that i'm going to
love it so i'm going to be really disappointed
if i don't wow and i knew if you watch roxy
you'll see she's a very very honest individual
so she doesn't like this she's going to let you
guys know you go follow rocks on social media
world girls channel as well where she's teamed up
with two other lovely talented women who aren't
getting invited here oh the shades yeah starting
drama today please don't show them this video i
i am not good with confrontation um but yeah if
you guys can leave a like that would be amazing
subscribe click that notification bell get
notified we got another movie reaction up have
you seen scott derrickson's other movies like
sinister or no name another one doctor strange
the first one yeah do you know how much i don't
like doctor strange they're off to a great start
there were asian kids in the 70s in colorado
we don't know they might get taken
oh man she's watching you
staring at us
you deserve to get kidnapped
no this does have a very authentic 70s vibe to
it you can tell the audio at the beginning too
it's like horror audio yeah yeah your arm is
mint you almost had good game mint in the 70s
dude this guy's having the time of his life right
now until i knew it i feel bad for joking about it
oh creepy it's the 70s so it's grainy i think
in like 70s 80s that's when there were a lot
of missing children and like the rise of serial
killers and [__] the milk cartons yeah exactly
well he's an abusive father you can just
tell mr yamada's putting them up again
you don't think they're gonna
find them too not how they want to
come on let's go we're gonna be late
i really love the way this is shot
yeah it looks awesome like a nail you scrawny
little [__] then do it unless you're scared
oh holy crap what the [__]
oh my goodness
oh my god oh my god this is really violent
feels very real coming out queen not fooling
anyone annoyed jesus is everyone here
a bully what you doing in our bathroom
huh see the sign it says boys yeah boys
[__] move
hey finn what's happening you know
just keeping on keeping on i guess
cool there who's
yes
i was so that guy when i was his age
which one you know that one yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna have to stand up
for yourself one of these days
i don't know i got cheech and chong shirt
you got time to stop by my house after school
is it math again mr johnson talks too fast he
doesn't explain it right not like you can you walk
me through it if i get another f i'm suspended
yeah sure i like them together friendship goals
i had a dream about it he was taken that's all
by man with black balloons in a van we found two
black balloons at the scene gwen and we never
release those details either there's a leak
in the department or what i'm the grabber no
vance got held back twice i've
seen him fight and trust me
he could kick the [__] out of either of
you blindfolded when watch your language
yeah i took him down cause obviously i'm
the grabber you dumb [__] fart knocker
i love her what aren't you telling us
that sometimes my dreams are right oh
interesting is she like a pr premonition yeah
power okay or maybe she saw it yeah it's probably
this pen's making a lot of appearances
oh no oh what the hell no
hit me again and i'm dropping
it you drop that and then we'll breathe
your ass towards this heart oh my god
no no no no god damn you are not your mother
that means you do not hear things they're not
there you do not see things that are not
there okay they're not there granny jesus
oh my dreams are just say it
again my dreams are just dreams
oh [__] this who's this little
girl she's amazing she is okay
this feels very much like a stephen king movie i
have like such a so much harsher than i thought
i love siblings though it's like that and that
moment where she needs that she need her brother
not him he didn't even say it
what oh man he was like the badass warrior one
and now they're gonna kick the crap out of the kid
do you know kitten and robin
ariana why were they walking
towards each other like that though
i know you think these kids would like hear
enough signs like maybe don't walk that way
yeah i feel nauseous right now you could
help me have a dream or two and just see
something that could help the police or me
or anyone find him i would follow you forever
no no no no no no
no amen get that button in there no playing after
live sound sorry daddy go to sleep i love you
you don't it does feel like a very
realistic portrayal of an alcoholic father
no i knew it i told you no no
no oh my god [__] cowards
oh [__] two of
oh my god that is he kicked her head
the bullying is so relentless in this movie
where are you going i'm staying over
at susie's tonight it's friday so
i'll look after dad see you kid
she is great both of them are
oh
you see that yeah would you hand me my hat do not
throw it throw it throw it throw it oh my god you
know this guy's would you like to see a magic
trick no yeah are those black balloons in there
oh my god
stop this oh my god
this is so much harsher than
i thought it was gonna be
i should snap your neck for what you did to
my arm oh what he did to his oh it was his
heart but that was that oh my god i was
like damn dude dude what was it the pen
that he did in his mind yeah i think he's
a rocket pen you don't have to be scared
nothing bad is going to happen here
i'm going to go get you a soda and then
earphone ring the black phone do you know who
that actor is ethan hawk that's ethan hawk i
didn't know ethanol was in this movie i think
i think no it sounds like him that makes sense
they worked on sinister yeah okay that makes
sense hi daddy no i haven't not since school
no night night time he's already
got someone oh i have goosebumps
if you try to touch me i'll scratch your face
and whoever's coming will see and ask why
this face hang up the phone
now he is creepy man yeah
i don't think i ever even
saw a trailer for this oh
it's like you can't there's no moment to breathe
no it's the call to black
phone try to use the phone
i'm not getting anything that's not true honey
pick up every time you don't know
stop it stop working oh oh my god
i can't bring you anything to eat
if you weren't gonna feed me
why'd you even come down here
i just wanted to look at you okay
it maybe it's like split multiple personalities
maybe i'm trying to figure out what the what the
ritual is that he has here that was different
hair too he's like it wasn't me yeah hello
did you catch what he said no did you
no i don't remember my name why not
it's the first thing you lose first
thing you lose win oh we met once
your arm is mint you almost had me oh [__]
it's the asian kid dig down underneath the
foundation i tried but it wasn't time
for me to take up and out the other side
hello
oh no is he losing his memories
oh interesting
that's gonna get backed up real quick yeah man
you think bruce is alive or dead i think he's
definitely dead he's gotta be a ghost
breakfast what did you put in that huh
eat it don't eat it you're already down
here what do i need to drug you for
those eggs look good did you not lock the door
no no no no no don't open that i mean
dude but don't i don't know i think
don't miss the phone call
no no don't go upstairs no
why not it's a trap fat fascinating
it's a homie oh [__] this is [__]
that really got me
do not go upstairs what is he doing
well i got nipple chills he's waiting
on the other side with that [__] belt
he'll beat you with that belt you pass out
you beg him to stop we all did
but he just keeps beating you
so he can talk to dead people and the sister
can see [__] yeah she could probably connect
to the dead in somewhere oh dude you're going to
go up when they said not to go up on crack kid
listen to me ah at least eat the eggs no no
get downstairs get downstairs get
downstairs oh this must be what she saw
when he was banging at the at the door
no that is messed up
can he see him right now uh his eyes are open
i think yeah but i don't know if he went
high enough up oh that's what you mean
see the walls separated from the floor
to our long cable loose from down there
ah well pull it down or at least be
able to reach there with the cable
what do you see
the paper boy yeah so she can connect to the dead
that's smart no no no no
what's on his hand
no oh what you think oh that's so
smart how did it just like magically
no he put it through yeah i know
but it's a strong it's a cable
it's a little more firm no no no
he's coming downstairs no no no no no
he's coming right now okay
oh smart yeah but then what
when he climbs up the wall
the guy's coming downstairs he's coming
downstairs he's coming downstairs he's
coming downstairs he's coming downstairs he's
coming downstairs no no no get your fingers away
stop no no
oh [__] oh that is too much
noise it's soundproofed your mother
she just became so convinced that her
dreams meant something and eventually
they told her to do things until she took
her own life so she can get in too deep
i don't want that future for you sweetheart
but what if it could help me find benny mm-hmm
oh wow that is unexpected yes doom graffiti
uh you're right for the missing kids yes
sir and if there's anything else i don't
know come inside come on samson stop it
all right let's show you something yes right over
here oh my god he has to be able to grab these
kids and get them back to his place very quickly
which means he's got a house with a garage how
long have you lived in the area max oh i'm just
crashing here this is my brother's place i've been
reading about this case a lot and i'm in between
jobs right now and you guys could really use my
help i want to tidy up before your brother gets
home there's something to the brother situation
is that below him i can't tell
if it's just a transitional shot
he said he's his brothers though tell me your
name what do you care i usually don't i find
out eventually in the paper they always print
a nice big photo what's different this time oh
duh dog you can blindfold me drop
me off on the street i'll walk home
well tell me your name taylor mullen
it's a lie
paper has been friends oh he already knew
yeah i was really starting to like you finney
see is it vinnie or finney what's going on
with the window thing that he pulled down
ah good question is his name vinnie or finney
it's an inconsequential detail at the moment
oh so homeboy just kind of stays here and
just waits all night what's he doing right now
i think he's trying to stay awake
how come last time he looked
ripped i know it's exciting
i'm not trying to shame anybody but no
i was like you looked like super like
yeah that's exactly what i was
thinking is it two different people
the mask is it two parts and sometimes he doesn't
like yeah where the top house
yeah yeah what's that about
it's an insequential dude no no actually
no i think it's important because with the
identifying as different personalities yeah
you're thinking inconsequential real thinking
what is it what is it what is it right now but
the sound got me oh my god it's a hanging body
it's fresh
why is it oh those are kids you don't have
much time the grabber hasn't been sleeping
he thinks this might be it that he's gonna
figure it out who's gonna figure it out his
brother upstairs though it is upstairs holy [__]
if you don't play naughty boy the grabber can't
beat you but naughty boy if he can't beat you you
can't move on to the next part you're the next
part of naughty boy this is favorite part he's
not trying to escape yeah what's the next part
you don't have much time he's not been sleeping
you said that too yeah he is
now in his chair oh oh my god
the door is still unlocked
there's a combination lock it was my bike lock
he took it when he took me what's the combination
oh yeah i remember being afraid to forget it
that's why i wrote it down what where stop
talking to the law man with a bottle cap in the
wall which wall which wall the one on your right
about shoulder height when you're sitting
down he's gonna play a naughty boy though
if he tries to escape remember when ethan hawk
said he had a visitor earlier on oh yeah yeah
two three three one something two three four one
second and you'll have to be very quiet about it
or just stay down there i'm wondering if
the brother is like a filmmaker mislead
like that actually is ethan hawk's character but
they just cast someone else's personality yeah
like the brother is one person like split kind
of thing yeah i know that's what i was thinking
before but it is weird that's different person
but how far they're upstairs could he be true true
it is shot so dark at times
he just told you if you don't go
upstairs so then you're never naughty boy
but he never escapes he has to take a chance
i almost just hit you yeah i would grab like
a fork or a knife and stab him you would
especially when he's in fat mode
god damn man figure it out just sign this quietly
don't be naughty boy don't be naughty boy silent
no so intense
no no he's waking up he's waking up he's
waking up he's waking up sorry sorry
the dog the dog
oh [__] he got outside
no no run dude run into like a neighborhood
did he hit him
like a pig right here in
the street the brother right
and strangle you with your
own intestine fascinating
i would scream anyway i would scream anyway
naughty boy i would have screamed while
i was running you get out of that house
you start screaming samson was barking at
something it's nothing go back to bad max
what is the structural layout of their house
three stories yeah what is going on there
i ask you for help when you give me these clues
that don't mean anything and now this morning you
wake up without any dream at all seriously what
the hell is wrong with you i'm with you girl maybe
you're not even real oh my god now it's time for
an existential crisis they're too young for that
[__] you
what do you mean they got you out man you just
you should have ran into a neighborhood scream
do you even know who you are what the [__]
kind of question is that you're a fan's hopper
you should scare me if you knew what you had
coming you'd be [__] terrified today's the day
it's kind of like decker montgomery
stranger things that's exactly what i was thinking
west side story
jesus christ what are these kids
why seven seven four one like a
satanist or something what is this tower
these kids are awful i don't know i'm like
shaking my body right now these kids are so awful
oh spotted
i spotted what the camera's focusing
on right now where's waldo way
oh [__] she's like traveling
through this tell them
oh damn i got nipple chills man it's crazy look
at that it's like stood up here everywhere you
even know who you are what the [__] kind of
question is that do you even know who you are
i'm finney blake hello nice to [__] meet you
finney blake right here this is it this is it
oh my gosh you could reach him your fence
hopper i remember you you should scare me
there's an outlet in the [__] across
from the john break it to the wall about
two feet above the outlet till you get to
a panel with screws in it get the panel off
you're into the freezer and then out to the
storage room thank you this isn't about you [__]
what is going on
wait for his sister oh no no no
no no no no that was disgusting
he was drinking toilet water yeah sorry
sorry you do what you gotta do man
what yeah how did that work
it's just the right size
what's that what is that what
is that what is that food oh
yeah it's refrigerator remember yeah yeah meat
it goes to outside i don't think
the fridge is on the outside
who's gonna hear him he's gonna
hear him he's gonna i i don't know
i think you have left frame roxy
you know same bro same
phone thingy yeah you gotta go pick up you
have no choice get up get up kid finney vinny
delayed reaction
hey finn it's the homie there it is we've been
waiting for him i'm with you i've been with you
this whole time yes a man never leaves a friend
behind hmm and i'm not going to leave you behind
we'll be together against you [__]
that you ain't gonna go like i did
you gotta stand up to him you gotta feed
him man do you remember what i told you
mm-hmm bruce lee movies there's
some dance to stand up for myself
exactly someday it's today finn yep today is
the day you stop taking [__] from anybody yup
not a fighter like you robin you couldn't even
take him you've always been a fighter finn
you were always afraid to throw a punch but you
always knew how to take one and you always caught
back up stop thumping you're getting out of here
if you can't do it for you do it for me what does
it matter because i don't want to die for nothing
mm-hmm i would at least have died for a friend
and because i can't kill that iko deputy you have
to do it for me yeah you are being a puta you're
gonna use a weapon phone fill the receiver with
dirt pack it in tight give it some heft you raise
the phone take a fast step back step forward
step back and swing god the black lighting
again you raise the phone take a fast step back
step forward step back no no you messed it up
i still be able to talk with you this was
the last call finn oh [__] what about the
pen you're right yeah use the pen well none of
the other [__] worked i mean that's why he's
got to stand up yeah but like why do you have
to go through the refrigerator thing why if
they knew it didn't work then don't tell them to
[__] dig through the i'm just pissed damn dead
kids please dear jesus please please i'm sorry
i said you weren't real please be real please
you watched jewish roxy yeah yeah
jesus gonna pull through today
i like the name jewish rocks the jewish
rocks in the house oh [__] oh [__]
you found it this movie has such
a great grip on atmosphere man
what the [__] detective right please
oh my god he's shopping i don't think
no i think he actually has a brother
he knows it's his house he
knows his house he knows
he knows he knows
did you hear me i hear you
kind of looks like jim carrey yeah i was thinking
that oh my god he really is putting it together
oh [__] i hope he doesn't mess him up with
the phone yeah he's gonna mess up the wrong guy
no way i knew that he was hiding something
from me down here a holy married mother of god
can you call my dad call my sister oh listen
don't worry he's not here he no oh my god he's
no no you won't know the story about how i found
you man no no no no no no don't worry about it
no bottom part for the first time look what
you made me do you made me kill my brother
no oh naughty boy now i'm gonna
have to put you with the others
looks like you'll find
those naughty boys after all
open up i would use a knife but you
are special vinny vinnie you're finna
oh that is cruel
all right you gotta find the other doors
go go go yeah it's gabrielle it's the
wrong house no it's not no it's not
oh my god
oh my god this is he's gonna kill him
this is for every single person
that ever bullied you you mother
you're gonna get the phone in the
middle of a choke what phone the
phone doesn't even exist anymore you filled
the phone with sand my dude it is for you
welcome to the nightmare end
of your pathetic little life
i can't kill you so finn is gonna do
it for me finn's arm is mint oh [__]
i did not see that coming dead or is he
not dead is he dead or is he not dead
we've got a basement
great he did all the hard work interesting
timing oh we got a piece of meat for the dog okay
i thought he scalped it oh it doesn't
that way so you can get the stairs
this is where he buries him
i think he kills them someplace else
what that's the hole for him
that's the hole for the kid
they're gonna see her brother's not down there
across the street across the street
is she looking at him yeah yeah
oh that touches my heart
that's so sweet
what a cathartic ass ending
man that's some crazy [__]
why was he burying them across the street
now beat your dad up i'm so sorry please forgive
me wow on an ending shot the perpetrator known as
the grabber owned two homes one where he kept the
victims while alive and a second empty home across
the street where he buried them postmortem damn
i thought he would be bigger he's the one who
killed the girl that's right you show respect
uh yeah you guys ain't bullying him anymore
go kiss that girl
hi finney um
i'll be finn it is finn okay
i did not know for sure until the very last line
that is actually the way they ended on that for me
the whole time like i think
it's vinnie the entire movie
great music too oh man that's an experience that
movie was [__] excellent yeah wow holy balls
holy balls holy balls dude i don't think there's
a post-credits scene trying to remember all
these names memorized out of respect yeah could
those fallen that was really really effing good
i'm sorry about your pillow yeah you've
gone down and destroyed that thing you
almost tore the inside of the cushions out on
that all right let's talk about it all righty
black phone well roxy what did you think you
gotta get stretching after that workout you
honestly i feel like i just ran a marathon
like i was going 360 man that was i thought
incredible yeah it was really solid but also i
feel like you set me up what do you mean like
i thought that i was gonna come over and
like have a nice chill moment and instead i
haven't felt my heart beat that hard in like a
long time it was that was tough i thought it was
great but tough i thought it was gonna be more
of like a slower psychological drama and i was
like this [__] is oppressive and making me tense
the entire time it was a real like tense thriller
well because when it wasn't physically violent it
was emotionally damaging so there was no breathing
because it wasn't like when we were cutting away
to the the sister that she wasn't [__] and then
when we're cutting back to him so there was no
we weren't safe anywhere no not for one second
and i think that's a big i love the arc of the
character though the main got finney finney we
nailed down that name every time you were saying
vinnie finney in my head i was actually thinking
come on roxy it's vinnie i was actually thinking
that i'm pretty positive at one point they do call
him vinnie and at one point they call him finn
i thought the dad called him i thought like the
dad called him vinnie at one point i think maybe
he thought that was his name and that's the true
problem with fatherhood yeah that's that's the
lesson of the story learn your goddamn kids names
but him learning this that the whole solution
through it all just leads to such a great
catharsis when he does stand up to ethan
hawk uh the grabber which i did not know that
there was ethan that com piece of information i
completely missed so i thought you were testing me
i thought that that was a trivia moment
you're like who plays who plays this guy
and i was like oh come on pretty sure it
wasn't my attitude when i asked you that
pretty sure i wasn't like that's how i felt
so rocks voices cockside huh if you understood
east coast you would get that that's everyone's
attitude i understand no so you know who plays
this dude or not you don't know no you don't know
i don't mean to challenge you my bostonian friend
he is so good so good and i can't believe his
agent let him do something where his face was
covered the whole time that's brilliant i love
that show i respect that choice so much i mean
it's got to be one of those like favor asks too
because he's he's reuniting with the director of
sinister like you haven't seen sinister right no
phenomenal that he it he ethan hawk is incredible
when are we talking about most like a couple years
ago nah like i don't know i think maybe like five
years ago or something like that is this is the
star of it he's the main star of it and uh it was
the same to writer and director oh i missed that
one yeah he's he's great in that film and that was
for a lot of people they consider that almost a
semi like resurgence of ethan hawk because of how
graceful in that film he is so to see him here to
be playing the the main baddie and also you know
he was just in moon night as the main
villain i feel like what he did here was just
exceptionally more creepy and what's better
sinister or this it just has a movie oh
it's so difficult to compare the two but i'm
asking you to anyway yeah you're being a dick
shocker yeah i i guess i would i don't want
to play this game i don't know like it's my
channel i don't have to play by your being
a naughty boy right now i don't like it
i didn't i didn't love the term naughty boy
throughout the entire thing i i couldn't help but
kind of giggle at it like the naughty boy thing
made it feel sexual well i think that's i don't
think that's the point though is this was i don't
think it's supposed to be comedically sexual but i
think a big part of it is to have a bit of uh like
i don't think he you know does anything sexual to
the children like directly but i feel like part of
it is a sort of lustful vibe what was what is your
interpretation of what was happening when ethan
hawke's character continues to be like i'm not
going to hurt you i wouldn't do that i've never
hurt any of the boys that wasn't me that took
them like is he what's actually going on there
i mean to me it felt like it was he's trying to
you know um uh i forget what the term i'm trying
to look for is but it's it's sort of like the
ring out that's what i was trying
to think yeah no no ring out
that's right this video is
right they're not real no uh what i think he's
the bring out i forgot my original appointment
i'm trying to make it i got some focus to try
to find the word you think that he's trying to
the um the you know i totally had
like a smart word in my head i did
and she got so caught up in butts and butt that i
completely forgot what i was gonna say i feel like
he's either what was your question my question is
do we think that he is multiple personality do we
think that he's lying to him like what he's trying
to do is he's trying to pull out like kind of the
the perversion of of innocence in a way like he
he plays on the innocent actually wants them to do
something bad and it's it is like praying on the
sin like he seems to embody this sort of satanic
like mentality they have this jesus symbolism in
there so it's i think it is about pulling out the
sin in there and punishing upon it at least that's
a part of my interpretation of it but i'm just i
agree with you there i just don't know whether the
movie was trying to say to us this is this man has
multiple personalities who and this one with this
kind of mask believes that he doesn't hurt people
and he wasn't the one who kidnapped those boys
but when he's wearing this mask he believes this
or whether they were just saying bad guys are bad
guys who lie and sometimes they claim they didn't
do something that they did do right right you
know what i mean at all yeah you're just trying
to you're trying to say that there's some version
of him that maybe doesn't think he actually did
some of this could be i didn't know if that's what
i was trying to say because he says at one point
i think very early on when when when the main kid
finney is abducted he does say i didn't i didn't
hurt i didn't say you took those other boys didn't
you and he says i didn't do that he denies it yeah
that's a good point actually so i'm just like
maybe some people just lie he could have just
been lying or there's a version of it in which he
doesn't that that version of him that wears the
mask like that doesn't think that he took the boy
but full mask version of him knows he took the boy
yeah whatever this greater entity is that he
fancies himself to be it's kind of like have
you ever seen a hannibal or red dragon that kind
of serial killer motif that there he is a greater
being than that so i feel like whatever entity
he feels he's embodying that is the thing that
is the the real pull definitely i was getting
m night vibes from it for the like the unbroken
split that whole with what was going on but i hear
you it wasn't as directly as a split personality i
think he believes that he is something of a bit
of a higher calling of some sorts yeah i'm not
i'm not sure but whatever ethan hawk was doing
it seemed very purposeful the entire time
the brother felt like he was in a different
comedy though like the brother was doing something
it wasn't bad it didn't take me out of it but i
was just like huh where where are you at right
now you coke you're a little you're like a few
years early to be blowing lines as hard right now
it was like a real left field funny thing to
infuse in the movie and then with the accident
yeah yeah and i wasn't even entirely sure of
the purpose of inclusion including him because
they were saying the grabber owned all this but i
guess it might have just been for the mislead for
the plot point element yeah there did seem to be
a couple on i don't know if they're unnecessary
because maybe if i watch it again i would figure
out why it's necessary but i don't know why we had
to have two houses and why the kids couldn't
have been buried underground where he was
because that's where their ghosts were
and i'm not sure why we needed the brother
to be in the brother's home but the brother's
not there and it kind of made us question like
how many layers of the house maybe something to do
with like the cleansing like this is pure here um
you know jesus yeah jesus [__] you know probably
just like jesus saying in you know that's what you
got to do at the end of the day just say jesus
that's what it was it was all christ allegories
the entire time that little girl man yeah what
is this actor saying we have the imdb pulled up
madeline mcgraw you s where do you see that
top right oh the very top friend there yeah
first name very beginning of this whole search
uh madeline mcgraw we don't look at it for
a second what was her the character's name
i would have when yeah yeah gwen man right
gwen stacy man yeah there you go that's
the queen stacy origin story and um
it was crazy that they decided to make this
gwen stacey's origin as well that little girl
slaps because i think some of the kids sort
of felt like child actors you know like actors
playing kids those two though felt especially her
even though it's a supernatural power that she has
she felt like a real child and they felt like
siblings too like that sibling connection i just
think it i i have a brother as do you i think
that like bond i'm a younger sister too yeah
so you know the the boy girl sibling bond too oh
my brother's older there's something about that
older brother little sister vibe that they the
dynamic that they showed where i was just like
yeah that's what it's like when you go when
it's you guys against the world it kind of
feels like that and i loved watching
the depiction of that because they
just genuinely felt like siblings that had
that like espn espn they had that espn cnbc
ah that's like that esp brother sister thing
don't do it man go away stay in the video go away
yes yeah no more i've said stupider things
there all the time um yeah no i think that
which especially when she is having more of those
like breakdown moments with her father i think
what they this movie did surprisingly well for
me was find a a rare gray like the dad's awful
he's [__] awful but they've managed to find
a a gray area for where the kids can have that
that understanding towards an abusive
father like know that he's abusive know
that he's awful but also the movie shows the
pitiful side of him and shows you when he is
like uh truly weak and then he's just a hurt man
and he takes it out on them so it's not that i'm
sympathetic for the dad it's that i can see why
the kids find that complexity where they don't
just like you know want to ditch him or they they
do feel that push and pull as well like it's very
real for a domestically violent home
of how they flash that out you know
that part does pose some issues as well though
because of course they have no other option
their mom killed herself so they have no
other parent that they can go to and it is
kind of that uncomfortable moment as an audience
member at the end when the boy is saved and the
the son and the daughter are sitting there and the
dad comes over to them and you're just thinking to
yourself this is what they're going back to this
man who kicks the living [__] out of them like
i get it's better than being in a basement
but like that's what life looks like
but i think it's also showing that finney every
time i say his name now i just want to laugh
i think it also shows that finney is no
longer going to take that [__] anymore
and he can he can be the man of the house now
maybe that's pretty big the sequel will be he just
murders his dad and now they're on the run i kind
of do feel like there is room for more story here
i don't think they could do a sequel obviously
because of the ending but what did happen with
the mom what are those premonitions or what
happened with the children too the dead children
are they just like tethered to the home or do they
get an opportunity to move on there's souls yeah
oh jesus jesus we were talking about the
matches jesus went in there he resurrected them
he just took the wheel and now we know what
happened yeah there's definitely created a whole
world like this this little not little movie
but it was a pretty short movie but there was
so much going on outside of our main dude yeah
well i think with the main dude it's it's a cool
i like the connection that by him defeating the
grabber it is him taking care of like a lot of
different goals of overcoming the the obstacle
like he will stand up to his dad needless to say i
feel like he will at least stand up to his dad we
don't know what the future that will be and maybe
there's i do like the ambiguity of we don't really
know what's going to become of the relationship
with the dad but then also the you know with the
children at school he gets the opportunity to
sh he's obviously going to get the girl and then
on top of that too those people aren't going to
bully him anymore this whole image has changed and
it's neat i thought i i personally thought it was
really neat how this whole movie he's
trying to strategize and get help
of how he's going to like sneak out and escape
from here when it all came down to i just need
to stand up to this guy the way how i've avoided
standing up to everyone else my whole life
and that was the key for them so it's i wasn't
expecting such a neat character arc to unfold
from it there's a really good point like it's
not about getting out the window it's not about
breaking through the refrigerator it's not about
getting out the padlock quick enough it's about
defeating the demon inside that's inside the house
yeah i thought that i i agree with you completely
that that was a really interesting message and uh
i would like to agree with you about the dad thing
that he's gonna stand up to him but i don't know
i if you are an abusive parent and then your kid
gets kidnapped and then they they come home and
you're still abusive how the hell with that i mean
that's how i feel yeah no i mean in real life a
dad would have to like do like years of therapy
and [__] and like really go to rehab like
there's there's a lot more it wouldn't just be a
simple i'm gonna stop in like in in the reality
of it that's what i was saying it's ambiguous
for it i mean your path is definitely the more
realistic path yeah realism like movie magic
movie healing movie character arcs they live
happily ever after or something like that i'm
like pull these kids out of school for a day
homie i know just keep making her go to school
and all that yeah i also really love the part
though that when his homie finally calls on
the phone the guy who was standing up for him all
the time and he says i don't want my death to go
without saving you or whatever it was like you
want to die for nothing die for nothing yeah
my words were better yeah yeah they were
definitely more efficient and more compact i don't
want my listen here's the deal my dude i don't
want my death to go without saving you though
that's the truth i don't want to die for nothing
i thought that that was really cool because
as a watching it i kept thinking like well all
these kids are already dead but it did feel like
at least they died for something at least
they they did help him to be able to live
that made it feel a little better yeah it's
true that's very true good point i i like uh
i like the children actors a lot they all the
dead kids i like the dead kids i like dead kids
it's just a great thought i like all the the
kids no no i'm gonna let you sit in that one
yeah not agreeing no come on don't leave me in
the coo come on yes and that's what that's what
improv is yeah who would yes give me a location
yes and i also feel strongly about deaf kids
in the bushes underneath the
stairwell with the wrench
actually you know if the kids were discovered
that might be how their souls like the bodies
were found that could be how their souls actually
escaped from being trapped in that location
what's your deal with the kids and the
souls you're thinking that they're no they
were definitely their souls were like trapped
there you you think that's what was happening
a thousand percent even though they're across
the street you get so caught up in the most
technical [__] because yo they're across
the street that's right it's like why were
there two houses no their bodies died they
they were killed though in that house yeah
so their souls were trapped though and but now
they're not because their bodies are across the
street so their body shifts or their soul i don't
know they were connecting through the phone ah
now you're now your semantics are making me get
caught up in the great part is this movie was
awesome but if i think too much about the soul
meets body you're making your own rules yeah cause
that's not what this means i'm sorry all right
this is just a little uh i'm i thought it was
whatever all right the sequel will explain
it oh what's it gonna be called blacker
pack the sand into the cell phone what it
doesn't even make sense i can't do that back
and step forward i'm still on the cell phone
thing i still have wi-fi why can't i just call
someone and get me out of here destroy the cell
phone with the dirt can't i just pin my location
get me out of here please no that's not how
it works i also think the uh setting of the
way they captured this was cool because it felt
like it was shot on film instead of digital yeah
especially with the the cool flashbacks i guess
i i want to call them flashbacks but they're
also the moments that the sister is seeing
so the premonitions but they were flashbacks
yeah they were kind of spliced together yeah
whatever it was that the the juxtaposition
of that how that was shot with how the rest of
the movie was shot was really cool yeah it was
excellent and even this the art this the whole
production design like it the cars the clothes
everything about it just really felt felt very
lived in there was such a great atmosphere too
to every quality of this yeah so surprisingly
because this could have been like a slow almost
boring drama but it or or something that could
have been perceived that way because i personally
like i love that elevated horror type of vibe and
it it kind of has that good blend of both where
it's like an entertaining horror film entertaining
horror thriller backed with being a little
much more elevated than that and more character
driven than that so i thought it was like a
good blend i agree completely and also i think
that one of the a big strength of this movie was
the fact that it was what did you tell me 95
minutes i think it's like an hour i think the
total run time's like an hour 40 but it's like 95
and without credits so 95 so no mommy being sexy
all right sorry possibly 96. i just don't
want to lay it down here i think that that was
i i actually couldn't have taken even five more
minutes more of abuse so it especially my heart
was like she started doing backflips at one point
i wanted to flip my whole chair around and i was
like i think he's gonna kick me off smash the
camera well this thing's destroyed now my nails
went into it your arm destroyed almost tried to
rip out the hair on your yeah i was like wow she's
really this is really going hard here yeah i'm
a grabber you're a violent human being roxy star
not after you watch this not comparatively
true not comparatively to actual murderers
you know what i'm not that violent
if you watch the phone you watch
this movie about this murder i'm less
violent than that i'm not that guy
that's hilarious adding it to my
profile we should end on that note
conversation right there oh yeah that was uh
that was a great film really impressed with
it shouts out to oh my god and the last thing we
got to mention the sound design was so immersive
from the minute it started like even you know
you know it's a horror movie when you put a
cup down and it's like and you just every sound
kind of puts you on edge makes the hair stand
up in the back of your neck from the minute it
started i was like oh and it punches to the face
that was like hammers into my little ear drums
i'm sorry i was hammering your eardrum
like a little like a little man in there
it doesn't sound like good sound design
that sounds like a very awful sound camera
sounds like someone was hammering my ear
drums no one was hammering my ear saying a
little man inside my ear being like creating
like the perfect sound okay kind of like um
like dopey or somebody yeah one of them
you're talking about the dwarfs yeah
they're not that tight i don't know if we call
them that anymore so i said dopey specifically
you knocked it out of the park i like
the music too music great do you want
to take it away on that yeah the music
was ideal uh there were some there were
some popular songs like someone was nailing
the music in my hair it's like sharp needles
i loved it so much it felt like
somebody was getting a screwdriver
it was like kind of a drill into my like a drill
bit you know yeah no it was interesting when
it started probably with its most popular song
that was in the whole movie i was thinking like
wow are they gonna go with how much money do they
spend on music but then there was only a few song
songs in it which i thought was a strange choice
the bullying was a bit excessive to me at times
sometimes it was like i got it you punched
him six times did you have to punch him 12.
but sometimes i was like maybe you did
the commit there's like this community
just seems like everyone's a goddamn bully
totally i forgot at the beginning they said
that it was in denver and then at the end when
the denver police was like this was in denver
just thinking myself this was a
different place before cannabis
they like that little moment when the guy she
hits the guy with the with the brick and then
she gets kicked in the face and then they're just
both sitting next to each other and both bleeding
and they're like yeah this is life this is this
is so good for the fact that he was clearly dead
he was on his on his way to die dude was gushing
blood from his brain yeah that like you got
to get it this you would have a concussion or
you got to get that checked out and sometimes
concussion he's gushing blood yeah no it's
that's like a usually when you see that movie
that means the character's about to die i
think i turned to you and said is he dead
is he one of the ghosts maybe maybe all right
now we're really in four more points later
all right guys well follow roxy on the world girls
channel just crawling around chairs the whole time
yeah you were about to morph into something this
was it's morphing time this was your wolf manager
yeah this movie did sound good to me
um yeah follow roxy uh subscribe click that bell
leave a like thank you guys for being here
we'll um catch you guys yeah what he said